حالته تسمم جديده لفتيات ايران سجلت في
عده مدن ومحافظات حيث لا يزال الغموض يلف
القضيه التي تثير غضبا في البلاد وقلقا
بين الاهالي المطالبين بايجاد الفاعلين
وبمحاسبتهم مئه تلميذات تعرضنا لتسمم
بالغاز في عشرات من مراكز التعليم ونقلنا
الى المستشفيات خلال الاشهر الثلاثه
الفائده التقارير من الداخل تقول حاله
التلميذات الصحيه لا تعد خطيره وانهن
يعانين مشكلات في الجهاز التنفسي ودوارا
وصداعا ولكن في الايام الاخيره توسعت
الهجمات بالمواد السامه ضد الفتيات في
المدارس لتشمل اكثر من 33 مدينه وبلده في
17 محافظات ايرانيه وسط اتهامات من قبل
سياسيين ونواب ونشطين لجماعات متشدده
ومتنفذه قالوا ان هدفها هو الانتقام من
انتفاضه المراه الحياه التي هزت اركان
نظام خلال خمسه اشهر من الاحتجاجات
العائمه بعض اعضاء البرلمان قالوا انها
عمليه متعمده وذات طبع امنيه الا ان
القضاء وسلطات الامن الذين وعدوا بفتح
تحقيق لم يعلنوا حتى الان عن اي تفاصيل
حول هويه الفاعلين ونوعيه المواد السامه
عدا عن القاء النظام الايراني باللوم على
المتشددين واصحاب الفكر المتطرف في حين
شبه التقارير واعلاميا ما يجري بالهجمات
الكيماويه لطالبان افغانستان والمتطرفين
في الشيشان وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبداللهيان انتقد المطلبات الغربيه
بالتحقيق في الحادثه قائلا انها تندرج ضمن
الحرب الهجينه مضيفا ان الاجهزه المسؤوله
تتابع الحادثه بجديه في حين يرى سياسيون
وناشطون ان طريقه تعطي النظام مع الهجمات
تعزز الشكوك والتهم حول تواطؤ النظام مع
الجماعات الفاعله والتي
[موسيقى]
هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا ينضم لنا من بروكسيل
منسلاوي الباحثه في الشان الايراني ومن
باريس وليد عباس المحلل السياسي اهلا بكما
ضيفي الكريمين واسمح لي ان ابدا من معك يا
استاذه منى في الواقع نحن امام مشهد يجمع
انتقادات من الجانبين في حين ان الداخل
الايراني المعارضين للنظام يقولون بان
حالات التسمم تتحمل مسؤولياتها اجهزه
شرطيه امنيه تتبع للنظام النظام نفسه يقول
بان حالات التسمم مستمره التي خرج على
اثرها او خرجت احتجاجات كبيره المتورط
فيها هي جماعات متطرفه تحدث عن طالبان
بحسب قراءتك من يقف وراء حالات التسمم
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني من يقف خلف هذه
التسمم في النهايه يتحمل الحكومه النظام
الايراني ان يعرف من هو خلف يعني هو هو
المسؤول الاول والاخير لانه لدينا فيران
اكثر من 17 اجهزه امنيه كيف هاي الاجهزه
الامنيه لا يستطيعون بعد اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر
والهجوم في اكثر من 100 مدينه وضحيه اكثر
من 800 ضحيه ضحيه من البنات لا يستطيعون
ان ياتون بمن هو خلف هذه الحادثه بالفعل
النظام خلفه لانه اولا يقوم باعتقال
الاهالي في حال بالفعل لم يكون هو خلف
الحادث لما سيقومون بها اعتقال الاهالي
يرفضون ان يقدمون تحاليل دقيقه ماذا هي
نوعيه هذه الغازات قدموا تهديدات للاطباء
لا يقدمون اي تقارير عن حقيقه
الغاز ولكن طبيب في احد المشافي المختصه
في الامراض التنفسيه المسيح تانشوري في
طهران
حسب تقارير الاطباء الاصابات خطيره جدا
فيعني ايضا هو قال هذا النوعيه من الغازات
ليس من السهل اشخاص مدنيين يكون لديهم
الامكانيه الحصول عليه فيعني كل هذه مع
بعض يبين انه النظام بالفعل خلف هذه
الامور حتى ولم يكن خلف تلك الامور هو
المسؤول الاول والاخير لحمايه المواطنين
لانهم يدعون لديهم القدره او الحق ان
يتحكمون في العالم الاسلامي يدعون يريدون
حتى ينظمون الحاج ولكن نرى لا يستطيعون ان
يحفظون على الامان ومواجهه كم ارهاب كما
يقولون هما استاذ وليد هل تعتقد بان الغرب
كذلك تدور في مخيلته شكوك بخصوص تورط
النظام الايراني في حاله التسمم هذه ام لا
ام هو يستسيخ وهناك يعني
امكانيه تصديق لما تروج له اجهزه النظام
بالقول بانه من يقف وراء حالات التسمم هي
مجموعات متطرفه هو تحدث عن طالبان
يعني سواء كان نظام الايراني مباشره عبر
اجهزته الامنيه واجهزه الاستخباراتيه
والحرس الثوري او حتى جماعات متطرفه كانت
مجرد اليد التي فعلت في الحالتين هو نظام
الايراني هو المسؤول نحن يعني شاهدنا
الامر ياتي في اطار تسلسل معين بدا
بالتعامل مع المتظاهرين والمحتاجين بعنف
مبالغ في وانتقل الى اطلاق الرصاص على
المتظاهرين ثم قام النظام باعدام اعداد من
الشبان الذين تظهروا كل هذا بهدف ترويع من
يشارك في حركه الاحتجاج اليوم ياتي
الاعتداء بغازات سامه على طفلات على
المراه يعني على باعتبار ان المراه لاعبه
الدور الاساسي في حركه الاحتياج الرئيسيه
اذا هناك تسلسل منطقي من الواضح انه يعني
يقوم في اطار منطق لترويع
المحتجين والايرانيين عموما وابع عن
المشاركه في اي حركه معارضه او حركه
احتجاج ضد النظام هذا امر منطقي فسواء كان
النظام هو من قام بذلك بصوره مباشره ام
قامت به جماعات متطرفه
فالنظام هو المسؤول اضف الى ذلك ان هذه
هجمات شملت العديد من المدن وعلى مدى
ثلاثه اشهر نحن شاهدنا اجهزه الامن
الايرانيه تلقي القبض على من يخرج للتظاهر
خلال بضعه ايام اذا المفروض انه النظام
بوليسي محكم على مدى ثلاثه اشهر تتم بس
هذا سامه في مدارس طالبات ولا تتمكن اجهزه
الامن حتى هذه اللحظه من تقديم اي معلومه
سواء عن طبيعه الغاز او عن من يمكن ان
يكون وراء هذه العمليه اضف الى ذلك ان
عمليه من هذا النوع تحتاج الى الجهاز ليس
من السهل ان يمكن تسميم هذه الاعداد من
الطالبات في هذا العدد الكبير من المدن
بواسطه مجموعات صغيره هذا هذا امر يحتاج
الى تنظيم قوي الى جهاز يقف وراء عمليه من
هذا النوع ولكن في نهايه الامر هو دليل
النظام يتحمل مسؤوليته ان كان يقف وراء
حاله التسمم او ان كان يتحمل مسؤوليه
الاخفاق في الكشف عن الجهات المتورطه
وايقاف حاله تسمم هذه ولكن استاذه منى
اليوم النظام الايراني وضع العالم امام
امر واقع وقال بانه هناك جماعات ونحن نعمل
على كشفها وعلى وقف حالات التسمم ووجه
رساله للغرب قال فيها بانه هناك مخاطر
هناك خطوره على داخل الايراني وهناك حضور
للتطرف وحضرتك تعلمين بانه هذه فزاعه
تستعمل من اطراف معينه لمحاوله ايجاد حلول
او فرص مع اطراف اخرى فهل ينجح النظام
بحسب رايك في اقناع الغرب باهميه بقائه في
هذه المرحله
يعني اولا لازم نرى تاريخ هذا النظام
النظام هذا
يتغذى على الازمات يعني خميني كان يقول
على الحرب الايرانيه العراقيه اللي راح
ضحيتها الاف عشرات الالاف من الابناء
الطرفين الحدود
قال ان الحرب كانت نع
مه لان الحرب
كقطاع ان يؤثر يعني يؤسس النظام الثوره ان
يقتل المعارضين ان يسكت اي صوت معارضه بعد
ثمان سنوات اسس الحرسه الثوري بشكل انه
اصبحت مؤسسه من الصعب انهياره الان النظام
ايضا يرى بهذه الازمات بالفعل
الحلول الاستمرار من جانب يقول للداخل
الايراني انا افضل لانه القليل اقدم لكم
الحمايه من افضل لكم ان تقبلون به والبنات
اللي يطالبنا بالحريه لا ينسى انه ممكن
باي فرصه اي لحظه ممكن نغلق المدارس وحتى
هاي المدارس هم ما تحصلون عليها كمان ايضا
كانت هجوم على مدينه جامعيه يعني منام
البنات ايضا يعني يعني يؤيد اكثر انه
بالفعل نظام خلف هذا الامر بل ويحاول يوصل
رساله الى الدول الغربيه انه ممكن ايران
تتحول الى افغانستان ثاني ونحن لا نريد
تحويل ايران الى افغانستان وانا اتي تحليل
اخر او ممكن نقول ايران حاولت يعني نظام
الايراني حاولت مع الهجوم على مثلا على
جامع شهر جغرافي يقول ان هناك مجموعات
متطرفه السنيه
وانا لازم او احافظ على النظام في حال لا
هاي المجموعات سوف ممكن يتحكمون في البلاد
يعني الحمد لله لا شعب قبل هذه الروايه
ولا بهالمجموعات لديها عرضه ولا هذه
الثوره من طبيعتها ان تكون طبيعه دينيه بل
طبيعتها المانيه ومدنيه هذا الروايه
استخدمها بشار الاسد قال ان هناك مجموعات
سنيه لانه شعب سوري باكمل يعني
الغالبيه كانت سنه وكان معارضين فاستطاع
مع الاسف واستطاع ان يتهم شعب السوري
بانهم بتدويرهم بالضربهم ضربهم
بالطيارات المجتمع الدولي سكت مع الاسف
ايران تريد ان تمشي هذه الروايه ولكن لا
اظن بالفعل تستطيع ان تنجح في انه تمشي
هذه الروايه لانه ممكن غدا يحاولون ان
يقومون بغارات جويه في منطقه كردستان
لانهم سنه وممكن نتهمهم اسهل بانهم
ارهابيين وهم مجموعات ارهابيين مثل طالبه
ولكن حتى الان نراه مع عاجزين ان يبيعون
هذه الروايه حتى مثلا نرى انها عبد الحميد
مولوي اللي هو عالم ديني سني نرى الشيعه
كل يعني هذه الروايه بالفعل انا ارى انه
يريدون ان يمشونها ولكن استبعد ذلك
تقول بان هذا النظام النظام الايراني يعيش
على الازمات يستغلها ويعرف كيف يستغلها
ان كنت وافقها اولا ما موقف الغرب من ذلك
خاصه ونحن نقف امام
الطريقين نقف امام ملفين ملف حقوق الانسان
لانه هذه التظاهرات في منشاها خرجت دفاعا
عن حقوق المراه وكانت المراه ابرز
المدافعين عن هذه الحقوق والملف الثاني هو
ملف تطرف وهو ملف كذلك ضوء اولويه لدى
الغرب فبالتالي كيف يرتب الغرب اولوياته
يعني المقوله صحيحه بالتاكيد ان النظام
الايراني يعيش على الازمات
والحرب العراقيه الايرانيه ربما كانت ازمه
ادت الى انتعاش هذا النظام ولكن كما نعرف
التاريخ لا يكرر نفسه وان فعل فان ذلك
يكون على شكل مهزله الرساله الموضوعيه
حاليا التي يتلقاها الغرب ان النظام
الايراني في حاله من التخبط الشديد لان
عندما نتابع تصريحات الوزراء والتناقضات
التي كانت فيما بينها والتي بدات من ان
هذا مجرد حادث بسيط رغم انه حدث في عشرات
المدن مع مئات الطالبات الى ووصلنا الى
انها من فعل اعداء ايران من هم اعداء
ايران لم يحدد الرئيس الايراني ذلك ولكن
يعتبر ان هذا محاوله من اعداء ايران
لخلخله الوضع داخل البلاد هناك حاله من
التخبط الشديد بعض المراقبين في الغرب
كانوا يعتقدون ان نظام الايراني ربما اكثر
ذكاء واكثر حنكه في في التعامل مع هذه
الامور او خلق او التحرك حتى داخليا ولكن
ما حدث على مدى
الاسابيع الماضيه هو يظهر نظام في حاله
تخبط شديد يعني
وزير يتحدث عن حادث والاخر يتحدث عن عمليه
تسمم نتيجه
تدخل مجموعات متطرفه حجه المجموعات
المتطرفه خصوصا في ايران لا اعتقد انها
ناجعه كثيرا بالنسبه للغرب لان الغرب
حاليا
مصدر القلق الغرب حاليا في ايران هو
النظام الايراني وطبعا بسبب برنامج النووي
وايضا بسبب تعامله مع حركه الاحتجاج داخل
ايران وبالتالي حجه الجماعات المتطرفه
اصبحت قديمه بعض الشيء عموما
وخصوصا في ايران رغم ان الغرب اعاده وضع
موضوع التطرف على طويله اولوياته وهذا ما
سنناقشه في ملفنا ثاني على فكره شكرا
جزيلا لكما من بروكسيل منا السيلاوي
الباحثه في شان الايراني ومن باريس وليد
عباس المحلله السياسي شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]